[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc la bataille a lieu sur la colline
de la Duchère le 19 février 197 Albin et
ses team sévère et ses troupes
s'opposent c'est l'une des deux plus
grosses batailles de l'Empire romain en
quantité de troupes et en quantité de
mort c'est vraiment un moment phare
c'est une sévère gagne la bataille le
problème pour les Lyonnais c'est que la
coort urbaine de Lyon au lieu de rester
neutre elle a combattu aux côtés du
perdant aux côtés de Claudius Albinus
cette team sébère qui a été gouverneur
de Gold lyonnaise il a très mal pris il
a autorisé quelque chose qui est très
rare c'est que c'est déjeuners ont pu
piller la ville et là on n'est pas dans
une ville lambda dans un territoire
ennemi on est dans une colonie de droits
Romains une fille de Rome installée
installé en territoire Gaulois donc
c'est vraiment une punition et la
première chose que les légionnaires ont
fait sans doute en prenant la ville la
ville de lugdun c'est de s'attaquer au
point un névralgique défensif donc au
camp de l'accord urbaine et on a
justement les scènes de cette bataille
qui a eu lieu à l'intérieur du camp
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les espaces extérieurs ici on a
énormément de pointes de flèche de très
de balises qui sont plantés dans le sol
on a des petits bouts d'équipement qui
sont tombés par terre c'est vraiment
caractéristiques des scènes de bataille
en fait on a retrouvé aussi une tête de
légionnaires décapitée dans le bâtiment
donc un crâne encore en connexion qui a
été rejeté ici et par contre on a le
crâne mais on a pas le corps ça nous
amène à une supposition on est encore
dans la supposition mais c'est que
finalement quand le camp a été pris
peut-être le centurion ou le légat qui
était encore dans le camp a été décapité
sa tête mise au bout d'une pique on a
pillé le camp allègrement récupérer
toutes les armes et puis la volonté de
cette team sévère a été de punir cette
treizième corps Turenne qu'il a dissoute
et il a rasé le camp tous les murs ont
été couchés donc tous les objets qui
étaient qui ont pas été pillés donc tous
les objets du quotidien tout ce qui est
pas vendable grosso modo et tout ce qui
a été caché nous ça nous a permis de le
retrouver c'est pour ça qu'on a autant
de matériel
et pour la plupart c'est des objets en
fer et comme tu peux le voir là
pour l'instant je ne sais pas ce que
c'est je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais
un système de crochet on a parfois des
systèmes d'enseigne militaire qui qui
fonctionne un peu de cette manière et on
voit des à l'intérieur du de l'objet on
voit encore des traces ligneuses de du
bois qui a été en fait fossilisé par la
corrosion du fer et on sait du coup que
ça devait être fixé en fait un manche un
manche en bois et puis des éléments un
peu plus simples mais ça par exemple
c'est un talon un talon de lance c'est à
dire c'est la partie inférieure de la
lance qu'on venait planter au sol là on
pense qu'on a peut-être à faire à une
variante d'un pylome ici on a un système
qui devait se fixer à la hampe c'est à
dire au grand grand tiges de bois ici ce
qu'on appelle une virole c'est ce qui
permet justement de faire la jonction
entre la partie en bois et la partie en
fer et on en a ici une
c'est assez lourd
ah ouais quand même
quand on est face à l'ennemi on va
lancer ce pilote et les textes nous
disent que grâce à sa longue tige en
fait c'est c'est Pilat au pluriel
ils viennent se viennent se tordre en
fait ce qui fait qu'on peut pas les
réutiliser l'ennemi peut pas leur
envoyer leur réutiliser ce qui est
de la joue de casque
à au clou de chaussures vraiment pas
trouvé de tout
dans la tête a été coupée ici
c'est pas très identifiable mais Charles
dirait certainement c'est un truc de
bouclier ça
à deux pas des théâtres antiques de Lyon
sur le site de la Visitation une équipe
d'archéologues fouilles depuis trois ans
un camp militaire antique celui de la
prestigieuse cohort urbaine de lugdun
c'est légionnaires qui ont pris part à
la guerre civile en 197 on périt dans la
défaite sur le site apparaissent des
vestiges de casernes une ruelle au
centre mais aussi un égout comblé qui
garde la trace de la destruction du camp
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
sous ces aménagements on a un bâtiment
qu'on est en train de dégager qui est
très bien conservé c'est une chance il
existe dans les camps militaires des
logements de légionnaires qu'on appelle
des comptes hibernats qui pourraient
ressembler à ça généralement un compte
hubernium ces deux pièces en enfilade
imaginons que ça c'est le pont du
bernium on a souvent soit une petite
pièce en façade une grosse pièce en
arrière sur l'inverse une grande pièce
en façade une petite pièce en arrière
mais systématiquement on a ce qu'on
appelle le Papillo qui est l'espace de
logement des légionnaires on a des lits
superposés on entre 6 et 8 légionnaires
qui vivent ici avec leur foyer leur
petit hôtel c'est leur casernement quoi
c'est leur baraque et puis l'arma en
arrière c'est l'espace de stockage pour
leurs mais surtout l'armure lourde en
fait qui doivent être capable de mettre
n'importe quel moment et qui stocke
directement dans leur espace de vie donc
on a souvent cette dualité avec un
portique en façade et ça voudrait dire
que Ben cette limite on n'est pas à la
fin du camp on n'est pas à une limite
entre du civil d'un côté et du militaire
de l'autre mais qu'en fait on est dans
un espace de circulation intérieure au
camp et qu'ici on a l'îlot qui est dédié
à la production au stockage des armes et
que ici on commence autre chose et
pourquoi pas des espaces de logement de
légionnaires c'est encore des hypothèses
il va falloir fouiller on verra au fur
et à mesure la limite elle est marquée
donc par ce mur de terrasse elle est
également marquée par un espace de
circulation G1 qui est la ruelle le
petit coupe-gorge pour l'instant on a
observé deux niveaux de voirie de bandes
de roulement successives bien identifiés
il y en a peut-être une troisième en
tout cas on en a deux qui sont
constitués de la même manière en fait
c'est un niveau de galet qui est disposé
compacté bien tassé et le comblement de
cet égout est constitué en partie de la
démolition du complexe militaire du
complexe de l'État 5 celui lié à la
bataille de Lyon justement et c'est pour
ça en fait que dans les goûts il y a
beaucoup d'armements qui sort aussi donc
c'est à dire tous ces éléments de
bouclier ces ordres de bouclier ces
barres de renfort qu'on va retrouver
dans la partie sommitale de l'égout et
voilà ça permet de faire le lien un
petit peu avec ce bâtiment et de bien
montrer l'abandon en fait de cet édifice
en 197 après son saccage par les par les
troupes de cette team sévère on se met
en bas pour voir dans l'autre sens vous
verrez les élévations un peu en groupe
et après si vous avez des questions
du monde romain et le plus important de
Gaulle en trois ans qu'on a sorti sur
une toute petite surface on a fouillé
600 m² en tout et l'autre proche de
recherche il concerne en fait tout le
parc de la Visitation donc tout ce
secteur qui est ici et puis on prospecte
tout le reste en géo radar assez corps
urbaines elles ont un rôle bien
spécifique c'est celui d'assurer une
mission de police évidemment dans la
ville une mission de police dans le
territoire aussi à Rome ça permet en
fait de gérer les conflits en Italie
c'est vraiment un honneur de faire
partie de ses cordes qui sont cantonnés
non plus sur les frontières comme tous
les soldats donc dans des territoires
éloignés de Rome mais dans la ville
directement à Rome donc il y en a
beaucoup c'est logique et il y en a
aussi à Lyon et à Carthage parce que
Lyon et un Carthage en fait il y a un
atelier monétaire qui permet de frapper
des monnaies et surtout Lyon en fait et
le principal atelier monétaire de
l'Empire romain au premier siècle après
Jésus-Christ et pour protéger cet
atelier il faut un corps de troupes
cette corde urbaine qui correspond à 500
légionnaires qui est installé dans la
ville on connaît bien l'accord par les
textes donc on sait qu'elle existe il y
a pas de souci par contre on n'avait
jamais trouvé l'emplacement du camp et
en fait ici il y avait énormément
d'ornements offensifs des pointes de
flèches des traits de balises des traits
de catapulte en fait des choses qu'on
retrouve rarement il y en a beaucoup
donc on se posait la question de savoir
qu'est-ce qui se passait ici et c'est ce
qu'on est venu faire et en fait en
fouillant on se rend compte qu'on est en
train de dégager le camp de la corde
urbaine de Lyon
alors souvent dans les péplums on
s'imagine la légion romaine on voit on
voit qu'ils se fonce dessus et puis
après c'est quasiment dû un contre un on
est là on fait des moulinets Gladiator
etc en fait il faut s'imaginer que mes
romaines avaient des formations très
très serrées et qu'au combat en fait on
venait au corps à corps et avec le
glaive le glaive c'est vraiment une arme
Destock c'est à dire une arme de qu'on
plante en fait on venait en formation
serrée avec ces collégionnaires en fait
et on venait
piquer en fait l'ennemi on a une image
de l'armée de manière générale que
quelque chose de très uniforme parce que
dans nos armées modernes en fait il y a
l'uniforme tout le monde est et ça peut
de la même manière etc l'armée romaine
c'est pas du tout ça on a une uniformité
dans ce que le légionnaire doit posséder
comme arbre doit posséder un bouclier un
glaive une lance une ceinture et un
casque par contre ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que il y a une très grande
hétérogénéité en termes de forme c'est
un couvre-jou de casse
sont tous différents après on a des
objets en os aussi ça c'est une poignée
de glaive
en os donc
et ça c'est une partie du
du pommeau de l'épée ça aussi c'est un
élément de pommeau
des objets
de ce type et tu fais quoi tu les
dessines alors je fais l'idéal c'est de
dessiner
ses objets parce que dessiner c'est
interpréter parfois sur des tout petits
objets la photo va pas être suffisamment
claire et donc le dessin à ce moment-là
c'est vraiment important et bon on le
fait aussi par tradition parce que c'est
vrai que avant on n'avait pas les
appareils photo numérique et tout ça
c'est marqué Claude de la Visitation en
2022 c'est pour faire notre logo de
t-shirts pour la fouille et là là cette
année je viens de passer neuf mois
plus de 9 mois sur le terrain
là je viens de Clermont-Ferrand avant
j'étais sur un chantier jusqu'au 23
décembre j'étais sur un chantier dans
l'Ain donc sous la neige et tout plein
mais après c'est quand on a une bonne
équipe que les gens sont soudés on est
enfin c'est difficile c'est sûr c'est
difficile physiquement c'est difficile
pour les conditions mais souvent on y
trouve quand même un intérêt je suis
bloquée avec lui depuis trois
vous avez pas de détecteur de métaux
qu'en fait le problème c'est que ça
fonctionne assez bien pour tout ce qui
est en cuivre etc mais on a testé sur
des par exemple à la pointe de pylômes
justement qu'on avait trouvé et en fait
on s'est aperçu que ça sonnait pas donc
c'est pas hyper fiable donc
qu'on pourra pas remplacer quoi
l'archéologie moderne à mon avis ceux
qui vont vouloir me déterrer c'est autre
chose sur une autre archéologie avec les
systèmes géophysiques et tout ce sera
très différent en fait ça se trouve dans
20 ans il y aura des meilleures
techniques qui reviendront fouiller ici
parce qu'ils étaient rond finalement on
a trouvé la façon de bien faire ça et je
pense qu'il y a toujours moyen de se
réinventer d'avoir toujours des mêmes
rien qu'avoir une vision un peu nouvelle
et un peu décalée de ce qu'on a déjà vu
ça aide à avoir une meilleure
compréhension de du de l'endroit qu'on
fouille
[Musique]
de nettoyer proprement pour le passage
du drone ce soir
des deux pieds droits j'ai jamais eu une
structure comme ça bien maçonnée on la
voit comme ça oui d'accord mais de base
il y avait il y avait de la terre
jusqu'en haut ou quoi qu'il fallait tout
descendre soi-même tout découvrir tout
c'était vraiment très très très sympa
de changer entre temps mais ça pourrait
ça pourrait fonctionner avec les goûts
hier c'était le carnage j'avoue
qu'aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir de voir
un site propre encore merci pour les
photos de ce soir là ça va être
dans la phrase
tu viens insérer dans un petit meuble un
coffret donc ça c'est vraiment plutôt de
la pièce décorative d'ameublement je
pense du coup c'est fait
pour le mien que de la céramique on a
trois sachets
en fait
[Musique]
c'est le premier chantier que tu fais
là
[Rires]
j'ai déjà fait du coup trois fois le
chantier à l'école de bibrac
je vais commencer ma licence cette année
discord de l'arbre archéologie
patrimoine que tu préfères déjà
je sais pas encore vraiment mais proto
proto antiquité romaine
et au Moyen-Âge
moi je suis un enfant du quartier
j'habite ici depuis 59 donc on est passé
il faut vers la colline qui prie à une
zone d'habitation et chaque fois qu'il y
a eu un chantier donc de construction
chaque fois évidemment il tombait sur
des choses donc moi j'ai vu ce
construire le musée archéologie que j'ai
vu se construire les
Visitation ici les le verbe incarner
donc il y a un côté très par rapport au
quartier on est là tous les matins et
puis
pratiquement et puis
bon c'est Rayane on voit plein de choses
non on se fait plaisir voilà on se fait
plaisir puis de mixer donc les jeunes
qui vont c'est pas le même en jeu
évidemment eux font leurs études font
leur travail et nous qui faisons du
bénévolat pour les aider
il y a un contact très sympa entre les
deux générations
[Musique]
de la comment on appelle ça
c'était les déchets de les Romains les
amports donc
il savait pas quoi faire de tous ces
déchets et s'en servait donc de remblais
quand il reconstruisait moi c'est ce que
j'ai compris hein
salut ça va ça va et toi
bienvenue sur la folie
[Musique]
vous remettez au travail
merci
donc non
pseudo sanctuaire le site de la rue des
Farges et nous on a les fouillé ensemble
de l'autre côté de la colline donc à la
solitude on fouille un îlot militaire
qui appartient sans doute un complexe
beaucoup plus grand qui correspondrait
au camp de la couverture urbaine de Lyon
à descendre sur la foule ça a été
intense d'arriver jusqu'au vestige
ça fait beaucoup de terres à gérer pour
la sécurité c'est toujours un peu
compliqué parce que tu fais quoi à
remettre 20 mètres
avec des gros orages c'est jamais
derrière ça
la colline de Fourvière elle est occupée
on va dire par la ville romaine on
estime à peu près jusqu'à la fin du
troisième siècle après Jésus-Christ
après tout le monde est en bas après
tout le monde redescend en bas donc
après on se met un peu du mal à savoir
ce qui se passe la particularité ici
c'est que des la fin en fait dès la fin
du 2e siècle après Jésus-Christ
justement après la bataille de Lyon
après le saccage de la ville par les
trucs de ses petits sévère et surtout la
dissolution de notre deuxième corps
urbaine qui s'est battu au côté
d'Albinus par ses petits sévère le site
ici est pillé par les troupes de Septime
et au lieu de transformer ce secteur qui
est quand même un secteur qui devait
être très grand le site est
littéralement en tout cas détruit les
murs sont effondrés on vient le
remblayer et après il y a plus rien qui
se passe ici ça fait dépotoir là mais
c'est c'est la salle de portique un peu
charbonneux il y a plein de céramiques
il va falloir qu'on fouille c'est
peut-être sans doute le dernier voilà le
dernier moment de circulation dans le
secteur disons jeté pas mal de choses
dehors par contre dans les pièces il y a
rien en tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est que
au deuxième siècle et même plutôt à mon
avis à la fin du deuxième tout ce
secteur qui est domestique et occupé par
un bâtiment il est totalement réaménagé
sans doute transformé en un espace dans
lequel on va retrouver pas mal de
structures hydrauliques peut-être une
place un gros portique on verra un petit
peu après avec les interprétations autre
élément qui est assez chouette pour
cette fontaine c'est qu'en fait en
analysant un petit peu les blocs et là
on refouillant ces derniers jours on
avait une rainure ici qui était remplie
de mortier hydraulique ce mortier rose
vraiment caractéristique on retrouvait
la même rainure sous le bloc et ce
mortier il permettait de créer en fait
le joint d'étanchéité d'une fontaine qui
était montée joint à vif il y avait pas
de mortier pour lier les blocs entre eux
et j'avais uniquement des crampons dont
on a encore les crampons qui sont ici
qui permettaient véritablement de tenir
l'ensemble c'est pas souvent qu'on sort
des blocs qui sont aussi gros que ça
rien que celui-ci qui est en cours de
taille on a fait les calculs de poids il
doit être à peu près une tonne 4 donc
ici on peut imaginer qu'on est bien 2
tonnes 2 2 tonnes 3 pour celui-ci il va
falloir qu'on trouve un système pour les
sortir du chantier
et puis ouais aller voir en dessous
documenter les dessiner aussi il faut
bien qu'on l'élève pour les décider en
entier l'image de la ville devait être
extrêmement particulière à la fin de
l'Antiquité au début du Moyen-Âge que ce
soit à Lyon à Vienne ou temps dans
toutes les grandes villes romaines étant
donné qu'on a une régression urbaine
extrêmement importante en Gaule à la fin
du troisième au quatrième siècle on a
dépend entier mais c'est des hectares et
des hectares de villes qui sont
littéralement abandonnés incendiées
qu'on laisse en ruine dans lesquelles on
revient ponctuellement enterré parfois
une partie de la famille ou autre mais
il faut vraiment imaginer que pendant
plusieurs siècles les gens vivaient
entourés de ruines plus ou moins
visibles et à Lyon en tout cas l'Odéon a
été visible dans le paysage quasiment
jusque à la fin du 17e siècle on avait
encore une partie dégradins qui étaient
visible sur la colline qui pouvait
décider de les payer ou non ça pose
plein de questions en fait sur l'image
de la ville sont devenir que finalement
on aborde assez rarement et qui sont
pourtant hyper intéressantes dans ces
problématiques d'extension régression
urbaine que connaît la Gaule et puis la
France ensuite au cours de son histoire
le Maroc
restitution de la ville tu as toujours
tous les monuments qui sont dans la
parfaite état tous studié tout doré
machin avec des enduits rouges partout
enfin en fait il devait y avoir la
moitié qui était braqué et puis on vient
squatter on met une cabane un bâtiment
récupéré un peu de matériaux ça c'est
vraiment une image qu'on perçoit plus
aujourd'hui je trouve ça passionnant en
fait on s'imagine pas en fait que des
gens vivaient dans les ruines
voilà c'est le soubassement d'un bassin
ou d'une fontaine
quelque chose qui à voir avec de l'eau
donc là on a juste cette partie là qui
est en place ce qui est intéressant
c'est que à la fin de l'Antiquité ou
peut-être au début du Moyen-âge ils ont
creusé pour récupérer une partie de ces
blocs par exemple celui-ci n'est pas en
place il a été basculé il avait il était
quelque part on peut être en élévation
sur sur ce soubassement il a été basculé
il a été en partie retaillée et puis
pour une raison qu'on ignore le travail
s'est arrêté là et ce bloc est resté là
quoi c'est le phénomène classique des
constructions romaines qui servent de
carrière parce qu'évidemment il est plus
facile de démonter un monument que
d'aller extraire un bloc nouveau dans
une carrière c'est déjà quelque chose
d'assez monumental donc visiblement
adaménagement public mais faut pas
oublier qu'à l'époque romaine il y a des
maisons qui ont l'eau directement
sur l'évier si j'ose dire il y a des
adductions privées mais la plupart des
habitants viennent s'alimenter aux
fontaines
c'est un petit peu les coupes souvenirs
qu'on pouvait acheter au Circus Maximus
c'est comme un petit peu le gobelet
qu'on aurait à la fin de la Ligue des
Champions avec le nom du vainqueur
couleur dessus on voit des reflets quand
le vert se dégrade il se délite en des
centaines de microcouches microscopiques
et qui partent en poussière en fait les
unes après les autres ça part un peu en
paillettes et en fait finalement c'est
le le fait que il y ait de l'air qui
passe entre les couches qui donnent cet
effet un petit peu particulier donc là
nous l'objectif c'est qu'on le fasse
stabiliser le plus rapidement possible
pour que ça bouge pas il aurait quel âge
ça c'est des objets qui sont produits
alors c'est très bien daté qui sont
produits entre le règne de Cloud et le
ring de Trajan contre les années 50 et
110 115 après Jésus-Christ c'est un
petit bout de rhum jusqu'à Lyon
oui c'est vrai oui
mais en plus on a l'habitude je trouvais
du vert et donc là quand on a un peu
enlevé on a qu'on a enlevé la terre et
qu'on a vu qu'il y avait un décor dessus
et moi c'est ma première fouille ce moi
je me suis plus spécialisée dans les
musées pour être chargé de collection
archéologique mais je voulais quand même
avoir l'expérience de fouille par
exemple je pouvais pas faire ça en
préventif tous les toute l'année
c'est fatigant c'est au bout d'un mois
là j'ai un peu mal partout genou et puis
partons de pluie sous lequel la canicule
la semaine dernière la semaine on a
une grosse défense de gros cochon ou si
c'est de l'ours ou un truc comme ça donc
c'est une défense on y va je pense que
c'est minéralisé
elle est partie je voulais arriver
discrètement et tout faire
échec
pendentif tu vois dans l'armée romaine
tu as des tu as des grades où il y a des
faux de bêtes qui sont portées par les
sigmins notamment en tout cas les portes
enseignes ou les musiciens qui portent
des polluants des peaux d'ours des pots
de loups sur leur casque est-ce que ça
participe à la tenue d'un légionnaire ou
si c'est juste un élément de
de voilà une amulette de protection qui
avait été monté sur en amulette ici sur
un sur une sur un tablier en fait une
languette de tablier ou ailleurs c'est
possible aussi
avoir je vais du coup appeler mon
collègue spécialiste de ça pour lui
demander ce qu'il en pense
on est mort
votre comportement est respectueux remet
en question la convention signée par le
CROUS pour accueillir le prochain groupe
et je ne suis pas sûr d'accepter
d'autres accueils à l'avenir oh my god
Benny va les éclater
moi j'ai rien fait moi je leur souhaite
genre un gond pour tenir une porte ou un
truc comme ça quoi je suis un peu déçu
faut pas le dire mais
plutôt plutôt pour une porte a priori
alors du coup il faudrait encore un
petit numéro ici mais qui a pas encore
été décidé donc pour le moment on sait
juste où est-ce que ça va et ce soir on
créera un numéro dans la base de données
pour ensuite le répertorier l'inventeur
mon plan
associé le matériel qui sort de ses
couches ah ce numéro du S voilà
un numéro du S donc US ça veut dire
unité stratigraphique et donc c'est
juste une couche un niveau
anthropique voilà donc fait par l'homme
enfin en tout cas qui est en lien avec
l'occupation de l'homme durant
l'Antiquité en l'occurrence là j'ai fait
un plan avec en rouge toutes les les
murs ou les structures en dur comme le
bassin que on peut voir ici le pilier en
vert j'ai inscrit toutes les fausses
parce que dans sur ma zone il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de fausses qui ont été
repérées et ensuite voilà j'ai inscrit à
chaque fois les numéros du S donc d'une
unité stratigraphique pour pouvoir venir
périr et
à chaque fois voilà j'en rajoute au
crayon gris je mets des notes à droite à
gauche et de temps en temps je refais un
plan propre pour que ce soit clair pour
moi
écartez-vous s'il vous plaît du chantier
là
on s'en fout il y a d'autres cibles ça
suffira merci
de couvrir un peu tout le tour du
chantier tu vois alors je me mets au
centre tu peux tourner un peu tu peux te
mettre essayer d'en faire plein le plus
possible
on voit du coup tous les murs qui sont
sortis sur la fouille avec ici le grand
mur égout
avec ces deux pieds droits là et là et
le fond de l'égout qu'on aperçu en
sondage et puis ici les
petites ruelle exactement passe ici
et puis là les tranchées de récupération
des murs qui délimitent justement les
anciens murs qui ont été récupérés avec
les deux les trois petits contreforts
l'étranger de récupération c'est une
fois que le site est abandonné les gens
viennent récupérer les matériaux pour
les matériaux constitués qui constituent
le mur pour construire d'autres
bâtiments donc en fait il viennent
récupérer toutes les pierres et du coup
ce qu'on retrouve c'est uniquement la
tranchée qui qui servait à
l'implantation du mur d'origine et elle
est comblée avec des petites pierres des
des choses qui qui sont pas qui sont pas
réutilisés à la fin du mois de juillet
normalement on aura dégagé l'intégralité
du bâtiment qui va de la bermicie
jusqu'à la berneula on aura plus cet
effet de sondage de niveau conservés ou
pas conservés et on aura véritablement
l'impression de pièces qu'on les verra
en fait une deux trois quatre cinq
pièces peut-être avec leur mur en terre
crue peut-être des foyers des
aménagements on verra bien ce qu'on
ressort et ça va vraiment ça va vraiment
avoir de la gueule vous voyez que ça a
du sens en tout cas ce que vous avez
fait j'espère que vous vous rendez
compte que ça a du sens
[Musique]
attention il est où 3 2 1
probablement qu'il est là et
probablement que il y a des il y a des
pièces à archéologiques uniques encore
dedans quoi ça on sait pas c'est ce qui
nous reste de la fausse dans lequel
était déposé le fabuleux trésor de
cobanous le pire nous livre un petit
dessin un petit croquis avant sa mort en
disant mais j'ai trouvé le dépôt à 12
mètres de l'angle du bois donc il a un
caractère exceptionnel parce que c'est
un des rares trésors de temple qui
parvient jusqu'à nous aujourd'hui au 21e
siècle et ça c'est exceptionnel pour se
dire une pièce telle que ces bustes qui
sont très beaux esthétiquement qui sont
vraiment des pièces tout à fait
somptueuses en fait c'est normal c'est
vraiment quelque chose de normal
[Musique]